This program is brought to you by Emory University.
[music] My family history is that I have no heart disease in the family
but for years I suffer from gastric reflux.
And the gastric reflux gives you symptoms very similar to heart attacks.
One night I start having chest pains
so I just say its refluxed and I'm just going to go to sleep and don't worry about it.
and the next day I wake up and I go about my life
except that my heart rate is higher than
usual.
Ernie started having chest discomfort that wasn't really typical of ischemic heart disease.
On the EKG it wasn't really obvious that he had any abnormalities
but he kept on having those symptoms
and eventually the cardiologists decided
to order a nuclear cardiology test.
We used the Emory Cardiac Toolbox to diagnosis
that yes indeed he he did have ischemic changes.
Usually the physician tends to
concentrate on the area that's
more severe, that's easily recognizable by just visual analysis.
What the Emory Cardiac Toolbox does is
helps identified that secondary that doesn't seem so obvious.
Because we're looking at the heart at the
molecular level.
So it's a really remarkable that Ernie developed the Emory Cardiac Toolbox.
A few year's ago Ernie was able to use his own technology
to save him from having a heart attack
or potentially more harmful complications.
So that was a little strange, [laugh]
to know that, to sit there, and see
the that tool that we developed being able to just see my heat there
and I was at that point very sure of what was going on with me.
So the Emory Cardiac Toolbox has at least 30,000 licenses all over the world
and to walk into a clinic you know in Italy
see that they're using your tool for
diagnosing patients
that actually was very rewarding. That feeling is very rewarding.
When it was used on me it was more like a trusted friend telling me what's really going on with me.
[music]